why are you doing this man for the doors
to be open yeah but you opportunity
opportunities he's under the impression
that the only reason the diversity
showcase even exists is because they
have to create something so that they
don't get sued by orbit get accused of
some type of discrimination so he's like
let's create a space for the [ __ ] and
groups all right so I would argue that
when you first moved out here there
wasn't as much competition would that be
true oh my god we're gonna get an
argument um yeah there was there was as
many as many what I mean when you go to
an Asian audition he would see Randall
Ken Jong you would see all of them
mm-hmm
you know guys that you're in a Brian T a
song Kang all these guys and there would
be one part in fact I auditioned for
King Kong what was the role if you watch
a guru long no no I auditioned for there
was one Chinese guy in the King Kong
that doesn't have a line but if you see
him being chased by King Kong in the
window jungle he's there right no line
right
you know audition for that who every
Asian actor in town in town I mean guys
that you know that aren't regular you
know like Randall people like that we
all auditioned for it and there was no
line and it was embarrassing because
they had you run in a circle in a room
and then they would that was that yeah
and then they sent the tape to Peter
Jackson
what was your running style yeah what I
need I need I need it and then my money
Kenya they said can you scream more
ethnically yes this is what I did I went
because originally I went I know that
was great Bobby stop kicking please that
was great but yes so when I started we
had as many but not as many roles right
so I think it's easier now but what Papa
did which is me right I survived
yeah me I fought my way to the top and
not top but I fought my way in and I'm I
have great agencies now I have a good
manager I do different jobs here and
there but my point is is that I didn't
have a diversity showcase so I'm asking
you Gilbert to get out of that
opportunities it's not an opera you gots
this hat because you're very talented
and funny guy yeah yeah yeah you do
you're right
there is no there's no work ethic
involved in his success that's all like
talent oh no you know how funny you are
it's not that my it is it this [ __ ]
guy I didn't like him when I first met
him and when it yeah I didn't I didn't
like him really until I saw him he
opened for me because he had never done
stand-up and I said will you do a show
you know and he goes I'll do it
no it's you do this show I will fire you
that's right that's my bad I said if you
don't do the show fire you know he went
up in front of a big room first time up
and destroyed
Wow and I looked at him and I went wow
this kid is talented so my point is is
that fine do whatever you want to do do
the diversity showcase but I'm not on
board I know okay I think that it's bad
for business I think I think that
networks and casting directors and
agents should go out and seek Talent
ethnic talent and I think that Hollywood
like NBC know these networks should just
you know have programs that are actually
gonna book people in the [ __ ] mm-hmm you
know I mean instead of saying because I
was a part of this thing called Cape for
years what's that it's an organization
led by a fantastic lady named Wendy Fong
she is an executive at Fox and she's
Asian obviously and she had this program
called Kate and so all we would go to
these meetings
everyone in Hollywood and we'd discuss
problems with you know and nothing would
get done you know it was just I realized
it was just so that we could feel
like we're doing something but it's like
you know it's got to change from the top
then but anyway you what do you want to
do I'm sorry that long-winded I Apollo
hey let me say something and I'm gonna
pry regret this but I sometimes think
like a funny white guy is a dime a dozen
like there are [ __ ] thousands of
funny white guys in this town and you
know in show business right and so
sometimes I wish that I had a diversity
no I
characters written also there's a dime a
dozen
there's a dime a dozen things written
for funny white guys so you are still
yeah you look at the breakdown right you
look at the breakdown maybe once a year
they do 20 let's say 20 comedies movies
okay all 20 of them the leads are gonna
be white yeah that's true okay two of
them will be allotted for they'll have
side guys that have accents or let are
or ethnic right right if one of them's
black which is usually is right that
leaves one movie here that one minority
right so it's Mexican Philippine or
whatever I might being okay and and
usually that role there's a lock down on
it so for years ken Jeong was that guy
so they take that away and now okay now
you have nothing now you have nothing
and then you have to resort to and
people say to me all the time you're
really funny you're so naturally funny
why aren't you doing more I want to I
never realized how privileged I am
[Laughter]
typical but that difficult funny white
guy
[Music]